On the
morning of April 5, 1943, about ten miles
off the coast of Brazil, a fishing family
in their small boat spotted a Chinese man
on a much smaller wooden raft bobbing up and
down in the Atlantic Ocean.
Waving a shirt and jumping, the man was clearly
in distress, so the Brazilian family turned
their boat around and picked him up.
Climbing aboard, he was overjoyed, hungry,
and very grateful.
As they set sail again, the man danced and
ate whatever was given to him.
After three days, they landed in Belem, Brazil,
a town at the mouth of the Amazon River.
Authorities were waiting for him as the man,
unassisted, walked off the boat.
Considering his ordeal, this was an amazing
feat.
You see, Poon Lim had been stranded at sea
for 133 days, a record for a lone human.
Born in Hainan, China, the main island of
a series of islands in the South China Sea,
Poon Lim attended school, unlike many other
kids his age, thanks to his brothers sending
money from their factory jobs.
At 16, Lim’s father, believing that life
would be better elsewhere and out of fear
that Lim would be drafted to fight against
the rapidly advancing Japanese, sent him to
join one of his brothers on a British passenger
freight, working as a cabin boy.
At first, according to his own account given
to Ruthanne McCunn in the book Sole Survivor,
he didn’t take to life at sea, getting sick
and teased constantly.
He eventually caught on to the ways of the
ship, but conditions were terrible for Chinese
crew members in general.
Discriminated against, given the worst jobs,
and shoved into overwhelming cramped living
quarters, this was not the better life Poon,
or his father, envisioned.
His brother tried to make him feel better
by saying, “Hey, at least the British officers
aren’t beating us.”
As the years went by, the conditions for Chinese
crewmen on British ships got better, mostly
because they had too.
The supply of British crewmen had decreased
due to World War II.
Merchant ships, in order to keep up with the
intense demand the war had created, had to
entice workers by improving conditions and
increasing pay for Chinese crewmen.
Lim had actually quit as a cabin boy in about
1937/1938 and moved to Hong Kong to enroll
in mechanics school.
After six months, the sea came calling again.
His cousin told him of the improved conditions
and, most importantly, better pay.
Plus, the Japanese were poised to capture
Hong Kong any day and Lim did not want to
be around when that happened.
Thus, he signed on working under his cousin
as a Second Steward on the SS Benlomond.
The SS Benlomond began its journey in Cape
Town on November 10, 1942 and was crossing
the Atlantic Ocean on its way to Suriname
(a Dutch-owned plantation colony in South
America) before sailing to New York.
The Benlomond was known as a “tramp steamer”
in that it did not have a fixed schedule nor
published ports of call.
Tramp steamers also often traveled solo, unlike
other trade ships that went in convoys.
The Benlomond was armed, but its heavy, slow
movements made it an easy target.
On November 23rd, more than two thirds into
the voyage, at about 11:30 am, it was torpedoed
by a Nazi U-boat.
The ship sunk within two minutes.
56 men perished, 24 British and 22 Chinese,
and only one man survived.
That man was Poon Lim.
In the mad rush of a sinking, exploding ship,
Lim was still able to grab a life jacket,
which likely saved his life, as he was, by
his own account, a poor swimmer.
He then swam away from the sinking ship as
fast as he could.
As this was all happening, he was spotted
in the water by the aggressors, the Nazi U-boat,
but was ignored, left to suffer in the cold
dark waters.
He floated in the ocean for what he estimates
was around two hours until he was able to
find one of the ship’s life rafts and swim
to it.
It was a wooden raft about eight feet square,
with a partial canvas roof.
Luckily for Lim, it had provisions on it:
a forty liter jug of water (about ten and
a half gallons), several tins of biscuits
and hardtack (a long-lasting cracker), pemmican
(sort of like beef jerky), malted milk tablets,
lumps of sugar, lime juice, two flairs, a
flashlight and even some chocolate.
This was to be Lim’s home for the next 133
days.
He initially thought he was going to get rescued
quickly, as soon as clients realized that
the Benlomond hadn’t docked.
So, he only partitioned the food out for thirty
days.
It eventually dawned on Lim that even if they
did know the ship hadn’t come in yet, no
one was going to come looking for it under
such dangerous, war-time conditions.
He decided that he would take matters into
his own hands; if he could survive long enough,
maybe the raft would take the current and
float to land by itself.
In order to survive, he fashioned a rain-catching
receptacle out of the canvas from the roof
and his life jacket.
He made a fishing hook out of the wire from
the flashlight and jagged edges of the tins
of biscuits.
For bait, initially he used bits of his hardtack.
Beyond fishing, he decided that he needed
to find a way to catch the other animal he
had seen on a constant basis while he floated
– seagulls.
To do this, he came up with a little trickery.
He took the seaweed from the bottom of the
raft, matted it down, and shaped it until
it looked like a nest.
Then, he let a fish rot next to the “nest.”
Soon enough, a seagull swooped in and Lim
went after it, eventually breaking its neck
(after suffering a few cuts from the bird
in the process).
He then sucked the blood out of the bird,
and dried the remaining flesh out with saltwater,
making perfect seagull jerky.
Because he was a poor swimmer, he knotted
one end of hemp rope to his wrist and the
other to the raft, in case he fell in.
By day 60, he was confident enough that he
began to swim twice a day in order to keep
his physical strength up.
Things were going as well as can be expected
until the second month when a storm nearly
destroyed his raft.
He survived and was able to repair the craft,
though he lost his water and food supply.
Beyond storms and the constant difficulty
of acquiring food and drinkable water, sharks
were also a problem.
They were attracted to the remaining blood
of the fish that he gutted and hung on lines
to dry the meat.
The sharks would often surround his boat,
even occasionally ramming the raft.
But while sharks are predators looking for
food, so was Lim.
He crafted a sharp hook out of a nail he managed
to pry from the raft; the next shark that
came close after he’d done this, he managed
to hook and pull up into the boat.
A fight ensued on the small craft, but Lim
ultimately won out, supplying him food for
days, including a Hanian delicacy – dried
out shark fins.
Poon-LimAnd so he subsisted remarkably well
for 133 days.
He came close to rescue three times during
the ordeal- once when he was spotted by the
crew of a passing freighter, who ignored him.
Lim felt it was because he was Chinese.
In a second instance, he was spotted by American
airmen out on patrol.
They even flew low to investigate, but ultimately
no rescue resulted.
This may have been because very shortly after
they spotted him, a storm came up and moved
Lim’s raft far from where he had been when
the planes flew over.
In yet another instance, a German submarine
spotted him and surfaced, but ultimately decided
to leave him to his fate.
This all came to an end when he found himself
being picked up by Brazilian fishermen on
April 5, 1943, about ten miles from shore.
Three days later, they landed in Belem, Brazil,
a town at the mouth of the Amazon River.
Upon arriving in Belem, despite being relatively
healthy, all things considered, and having
only lost about 20 pounds during his voyage,
he spent four weeks at the local hospital.
When he was released, the British consul arranged
for him to go to Britain, where he was given
a British Empire Medal by King George VI.
The Royal Navy was so impressed by his survival
skills and story that they incorporated his
techniques into their manuals.
After the war, he wanted to emigrate to the
US and, despite initial difficulty due to
the Chinese immigration quota having been
met (this would exist in the US until 1965),
he was eventually allowed into the United
States thanks to special legislation written
by Democratic Senator Walter Magnuson of Washington.
Poon Lim lived to the age of 72, passing away
in 1991.
To this day, he still holds the official record
for longest time for a lone person to survive
being adrift at sea in a life raft.
When told this in 1943, Poon Lim responded,
“I hope no one will ever have to break that
record.”